今日はなんとなんとですねお前たち
ご飯は好きかいまっはいっ
まあご飯っていう基本的に味付4セルモノっていうイメージからですなーまぁわかるは
から皆さんの言ってることもわかる
白ご飯の白花んですよ美味しいんですけれども味付けをすることで高いろんなご飯を
楽しめるっていうでね
cure まあ皆さん知ってると思いますサンター
ブーブとどらーん
ご飯もすごい左端ダイエットごはんこの最強に美味し2つを混ぜると
ダーヌー
時だったらクソ不味くて夜ご飯ちゃんに会っちゃうんで
な今実は大食堂ぜってーねーと思ったらなぁーぜってー名と思って食ったら本当にまず
きて
まあそれ以来ちょっと山たければまず降ったんですけれども
僕くらいのも21歳ということでまぁ小学校んとして来られてねまぁ
したの右手も変わってね色んな種類の食べ物をまあこの神社中で食ってきたわけなんで
まあ
大人になったところはねまあしょうだこのだけ飲めなかったね
ごはんにファンタグレープをかけてもでもね意外とは美味しく食べれるんじゃない
かっていうねこれやったことない奴ほんとにちょっとわからないと思うけど本当に
まずいからご飯の良いところとファンタのいいところを全部消しちゃってるみたい
逆にすげーこいつらはもうマジ見なくこんなにも会わない奴がいるかってくらいまあ
合わないんで
まあぜひね家族の人にバレないようにこっそりやってみてください
普通に来たら美味しいんだよ4まあ実験の一つと思ってくれてるんで買わない
いやいいんだよ生姜からの時の俺とは違うから
ん
そこをやっぱりこうわかってほしいね
いかに俺が強くなったろ
おは c
まじかー
想像つかない想像つかないですよこれのすごいところは
ご飯おいしい資産たグレープめちゃくちゃ美味しいんですよ
じゃあ行きます
本当にこの一家行ったほうがいいびっくりするぐらいね味がおかしくないか
はぁうわぁ
me
武藤頭になるだろうものにブドウをかけるというこのね
スーパブラー
じゃあ思い出す久津なんかやばいやばいやばいっ
大丈夫大丈夫大丈夫オレはあの時と違う俺は大きくなったんだ
身も心も
食べます
ます
これなーほんとなんかすごいよだめだ出てくるレベルなんですよまずちょっとまずいん
だけど驚きの方がでかいっていうこんなにも会わないかっていう c なんですよ本当
に彫って法を食ったらつげんよくこんなの見つけたら俺って思うね
もう腹実験での実験1回やってみてください
けど親にバレたら怒られるであとを残しもダメなんで自己責任でやりましょうね
おっ
ん
なんか昔より食える気がするっていうって
true
ん
スプーン
今聞こえたまふ
いいからをとってたからねこう思ってラストです
ああああああ
よろしかっ
ぶううううううっ
まあまず一口二口のは全定期ですよ
まずい不思議な味だけ泣いてが終わるんですけど
食い続けるとものすごい大とかで押されますそこの重機ある少年たち
を残しちゃダメだからなを残ししちゃダメだけどまぁ1回経験しておいたらね
いいと思います以上今日のドクター始めでした
じゃあ何